okay hello everyone uh
welcome to another episode of
science and technology q a for kids and
others
where i will attempt to answer all kinds
of questions about um
science and technology
so
let's see
okay here's a fairly straightforward one
what is the difference between bits and
bytes bytes b y t e s
uh people often talk about computer
kinds of things
in terms of
uh bits and bytes
okay so what is a bit a bit
is
just a single
uh a single piece of information a zero
or a one
it's something it's uh something is
there or not there it's it's something
that can be represented as zero it's not
there one it's there just one thing
a byte
is a collection of eight such things
so
in a byte there are eight bits
and each bit can be either zero or one
so if you think about let's let's say
there were two bits in a byte
then the number of different possible
forms of the whole byte would be four
because it's two times two there are uh
two possibilities for the first bit two
plus votes is the second bit so that's
that will be either zero zero zero one
one zero one one
uh the corresponding thing for eight
bits is
uh two times two times two times two
eight times otherwise known as 2 to the
power 8 otherwise known as 256.
why um
the
um
why do these things what are these
things for
well
when
one constructs memories for computers
in the end
one is dealing with individual bits
either there is a piece of essentially
electric charge
somewhere or there isn't that's if there
is it corresponds to one actually it's
sometimes reversed but but for the first
approximation when when it is there it
counts as a one when it isn't there it
counts as a zero and there are many
different
ways of representing a bit
in
uh different
sort of electronic systems
these days
most electronic systems are well
essentially the the the the main memory
of a computer
is uh ram random access memory random
access memory means you can pull out but
let me come to that later um but in the
end the memory anything that is stored
in computer memory as is stored as a
collection of bits
and those bits are represented by the
presence of some some electric charge in
the in the semiconductor chip or the
absence of it um when if for example you
are
sending data over
uh over a network
um a bit a one might be
there is radio energy at that moment in
a wi-fi signal or there isn't that would
be a zero
or there is if it's a um
if it's on a wire electrical wire it
would be like a network cable it would
be there is a voltage a a pushing of
electrons through the wire at that
moment and there isn't at the next
moment and when there is a voltage
pushing then that corresponds to a one
bit and when there isn't it corresponds
to a zero bit again in in actuality
these things are done a little bit more
complicated ways like like for example
just to explain that one
uh it turns out not to be a particularly
good idea if you are just sending lots
of zeros to say okay that's no voltage
at all it turns out to be a better idea
to encode these things in such a way
that you're kind of uh feeding them
through technically linear feedback
shift register sequences so that you
effectively are are making the thing
that represents all zeros to be some
some whole pattern of ones and zeros and
the thing that represents or wants to be
some pattern of ones and zeros so you
don't have kind of the the all ones
being much more voltage and the all
zeros being much less voltage you're
kind of splitting those two
uh
those things into you you're kind of uh
combining them with something which
makes them be more evenly split between
zeros and ones
so
why does the concept of bite even exist
why does one deal with eight bits at a
time
uh that's something that sort of emerged
historically in the computer industry um
when i was a kid for example
the computer that i used didn't have
bytes
um it had bits it had um
uh
it had um uh and it had
so-called computer words
and the idea of a computer word is it's
a collection of bits
which will all be brought in together
to the central processing unit of the
computer to be processed so for example
the bits in a word might represent a
number an integer you'd write it out in
binary in base two uh instead of writing
out digits zero through nine you're just
writing out the digit zero and one and
you represent numbers that way um
and uh
uh but the idea is of a word is that's
the unit of stuff from memory that you
pull into the cpu all at a time
and um in the early days of computers
uh
that's kind of what one talked about is
the bits and words of computer memory
and
it's not so useful to pull just
individual bits from the computer memory
into the cpu because to represent a
number you might use i don't know 32
bits for example or you might use some
number of bits
and that will be your way of
representing a number or for example you
want to represent i think i've talked
about this before you want to represent
a character
um like a letter a or something
there is a a um
for the 26 lessons of the alphabet and
the 26 uppercase letters and so on you
can represent
all of those as
patterns of bits that fit into
let's say an 8-bit
block there are 256 possibilities for
that eight bit block which is enough to
represent lowercase and uppercase
letters and so on
and so the the the original idea was
words are the things that you typically
operate on with the instructions of the
computer
bits are the underlying uh sort of
elements
of memory in the computer okay so that
was a that some might have been a good
idea but then people would choose
different word lengths so for example
the first computer i used had an 18-bit
word length
so whenever it was retrieving things
from memory it would come in 18-bit
blocks and whenever it was representing
numbers it would represent numbers
uh using um
uh the the um
uh using 18-bit sequences so we can work
out what that means so for example if
you have an integer
a whole number
and you're trying to represent it with a
sequence of zeros and ones
so the way that the the way that one
uh represents things in binary you know
the number one is just a one
then a two is one zero that's a a one in
the two's column and a zero in the in
the units column and then three is one
one and then four is one zero zero five
is one zero one
uh
six is one one zero seven is one one one
and so on and and you're that's that's
how you count up in binary so if you
have a length two to the eight if you
have an 18
bit well the more common case if you
have a 16-bit word there will be 665
six
you will be able to count up to sixty
five thousand five hundred and thirty
six five five three five
um six five five three five
um sixty five thousand
335 will be the maximum number you can
represent because that's a sequence
of uh 16 ones
that's the number that they represent
now there's some trickiness when you're
dealing with for example if you want to
encode both positive and negative
numbers
um you have to use essentially one of
the bits to represent the presence of a
minus sign that's not actually how it's
done usually what's done is what's
called two's complement or
numbers um where you're kind of flipping
the role of zeros and ones for things
which are
uh negative numbers and then the top bit
is a one if it's negative and a zero if
it's if it's positive
so in any case the the um uh for an
18-bit
word computer
that means you have 65 000 times four
um so about 250 000 possibilities for
the integers that you can use so you can
store an integer up to about 250
000
with in one word of that computer memory
okay so what happened is
there were
people started
talking about computers in terms of
their word length they were kind of
8-bit computers which had 8-bit words
there were 16-bit computers 32-bit
computers
and 64-bit computers so roughly
historically what happened is
the the very earliest microprocessor
chips were 8-bit kinds of things even
today there are 8-bit processors that
are used for very low-level purposes
um but then by
when personal computers started to get
used
there were
um
those were mostly 16-bit
um
they used
microprocessors that were basically
16-bit microprocessors
then by the time
uh
the bigger computers and the computers
that started emerging in the 1980s as
sort of personal like computers
uh were
32-bit computers in the sense that their
primary word length was 32 bits
and then
in the 90s and 1990s
people started using 64-bit word length
computers but the problem is the point
is
that depending on what you want to use
the data in your computer for you
sometimes want
to use uh for example let's talk about
integers
if you are storing something where the
value of the thing is always between 0
and 255 you might as well use a single
byte just eight bits if you're storing
something that is less than 65 000 use
16 bits
if you're using if you need to store
something that's less than uh either 2
billion or 4 billion use 32 bits
and if you want to store something even
bigger use 64 bits
and so what started happening is that
computers instead of just having a
particular word length where they would
always gulp in memory in that that size
words that started to be instructions
that were do this for 16-bit integers do
this for 32-bit integers do this for for
64-bit integers and so on and so that
meant that it was no longer sensible to
talk about bits and words and so the
idea of bytes came in as a
representation of this clump of eight
bits
and i think it was first driven by
uh
for sort of um
uh english language type character sets
the fact that you can fit the
representation of all the letters of the
alphabet and so on into one bite the 256
possibilities of one byte
um
the
so
uh
this
the thing that so so why have people
even worried about
16-bit 32-bit
uh kinds of computers well one problem
is when you have an integer
and let's say you're counting up and
counting up and counting up let's say
you're storing that integer in eight
bits
single byte
and you count up start from zero one one
zero one one one zero zero et etc keep
counting up keep counting up what
happens when you get to 255 which is a
sequence of eight ones
what happens when you count up again
well you wrap around you get back to
zero again you you do a carry it's like
having in decimal you'd have a bunch of
99999s you add one to that you get one
zero zero zero but if you didn't have
room for that extra one if you didn't
have enough places to put that extra one
if you didn't have enough bits in the
case of the binary number to store that
extra one you wrap around to zero again
and there are many purposes for which
that is a total disaster to have you
think you're counting up but actually
you get to the point where you wrapped
around and got to zero again
uh famously there was a missile system
that had a counter that would count up
over time
and um it uh
this was in the 19
actually even the early 1990s
um it would it would count up or count
up
and unfortunately it when it got to
uh it was a 16-bit counter and it was
counting up every second or something
and after 65 000 seconds um if it was
left switched on or whatever it would
wrap around and then it would get very
confused um and a typical thing you
might do let's say you store
the uh the date when you created a file
uh you store that as a number let's say
you store it a very common way to to
represent um uh dates of files is the
number of seconds since nineteen since
january first 1970 um when this file was
created you've got all these numbers but
you don't have quite enough
um you don't have enough digits
and you keep you you you think you're
comparing two that you've kind of run
out of digits
and um
then uh the comparison doesn't work a
very famous example of this was the y2k
problem
that happened in the year 2000
um
not this doesn't specifically relate to
bits and bytes but it still relates to
the ways that people stored numbers and
computers
um
the uh what had been done
from the earliest computers in the 1950s
and so on people had said
oh the year
for a date can just be specified by two
digits because it might be 1955 would
just be 55 it might be 1963 63. it's all
good
well it's all good until you reach the
year 2000
and in the year 2000 you will have you
know you'll go from nine nine
back to zero zero
and so then if you're making a
comparison is this date after that date
it'll go wrong
and uh uh the um
and for example for people who were
lucky enough to be 100 years old in the
year 2000 all kinds of strange um
uh kind of um uh medical record type
things were happening of people um or
had the potential to happen of people
being you you know you must be a newborn
now um because the uh uh the date when
you were your date of birth we can
calculate what is the difference between
the date today and your date of birth oh
it's only two weeks well actually it
should have been 100 years plus plus two
weeks
well
in any case the there was a huge kind of
uh
uh concern that the world would end at
um uh at the moment of uh midnight
between um uh 1999 and the year 2000
um
and uh
there was an awful lot of push to
upgrade computer systems to be able to
deal with
four
four number dates rather than two number
dates
in the end it wasn't really a very big
deal
no
no dramatic mistakes were made no
dramatic systems failed or anything like
that as a matter of fact there's another
one of these coming up in the year 2038
um
the uh the thing i mentioned of storing
number of seconds since 1970 um
that uh let's see what will that be
getting to that will be getting to
uh the place where with 31 bits i think
maybe 32 bits
um you run out of uh uranium numbers and
that will wrap around again
so if people haven't fixed it by the
year 2038 for most computers that will
be another instance of the y2k type
problem um happening again
but uh
so
what typically is done on computers
these days is you will be dealing with
uh instead of dealing with words nobody
really defines the word length of a
computer anymore well sometimes they
sometimes you talk about
for some very small computers for some
uh microcontrollers and things like that
you will discuss that 16 bits
and so on um but for for
sort of genuine computers it's usually
not talked about because what's what's
really happening is
that the um uh
uh that the it's it's a question of
which instructions you use in the
operating system okay there's another
wrinkle on this whole thing
which has to do with the way that you
address pieces of memory so you're
storing all this data in memory and you
specify it by where a memory it is and
the where is specified by memory address
and that address is again a number
and the question is how big can that
number be and if that number is going to
fit in let's say 32 bits
the maximum size of that number
is
well basically 2 to the power 32
roughly 4 billion
so that means that if you are going to
specify addresses in the memory of a
computer in a 32-bit
in 32 bits
you end up
only being able to address
4 billion different locations in the
computer's memory um and uh
typically you specify locations by their
you specify
byte locations you don't specify bit
locations you specify the byte eight bit
locations and those are
those addresses if you are only having a
32-bit
uh um
specification of the addresses you can
only deal with 4 billion bytes
um i i should say that that
in uh this sort of evolution of
computers of how much memory can they
address
uh the the sort of the common thing up
until a few years ago
was the limit is four billion bytes
um four gigabytes um actually the limit
was often two gigabytes because the last
bit got used for special special
purposes and you couldn't use it to
specify an address in memory
uh well then that really wasn't enough
because there are plenty of things that
are larger than two gigabytes four
gigabytes whatever um even you know
uh well lots of kinds of data whether
they're movies or other kinds of things
get to be longer than that
high resolution you know movie uh
data things and things of this kind so
there's a big push
to move everything to 64-bit
uh to use 64-bit addresses
and that was not so much a problem for
the hardware of computers because that
had already been set up to be able to
use 64 bits it was a problem for
software on computers and operating
systems for example would be assuming 32
bits and then they would have to be
revised to be 64 operating systems and a
lot of software had to be revised that
way and certainly for
language we had a big effort to revise
things to work so that everything could
be stored in a 64-bit way
64 bits
um you get to have uh let's see it must
be a billion trillion uh different
possibilities a billion trillion um
uh bytes of memory
which is probably going to be enough for
a while
uh and that's i mean so 64 bits has sort
of become the standard for for typical
computers of um uh the the
length of an address
um and
the the way that you can specify
positions in memory
now just to uh i'm not sure how much
detail to get into here but perhaps
people might find interesting some of
the actual issues with this so
when computers fetch data from memory
although you can in principle say
i want data starting at this particular
byte
most modern computers do not do that
very efficiently most modern computers
actually gulp things from memory in
larger chunks
um
and uh so
one of the issues when you set up
software
is that you want to align various kinds
of data structures so that they're
aligned on at least 64-bit maybe 128-bit
256-bit boundaries so you're not ending
up requesting sort of a bite from this
chunk and a bite from that chunk it's
almost as if the modern version of this
idea of word length has become these big
chunks that get pulled into memory uh
pulled into the cpu together and and i
mean again more technical detail but the
way computer memories are set up there
are usually different levels of
hierarchy of the computer memory there's
a a very big memory that's kind of slow
to get things from and then there are
sequence of levels of cache
which are where you kind of move things
into that faster memory
but you can't move as much into the
faster memory and then it becomes a big
issue for operating systems to
figure out what is worth moving into the
fast cache memory uh
because it's likely to get used in a
computation that you're doing so they're
typically level one level two caches
things like this there are different
speeds and different sizes and there are
lots of algorithms that have to do with
figuring out okay
you are kind of iterating over some
array of data you're looking at this
then this then this then this okay the
computer can predict you're probably
going to want to look at something uh
further down the array soon so pre-fetch
that stuff
into the cache memory um
so that it is ready so you don't have to
go and fetch it from main memory um and
so that's that's uh that's sort of part
of that that story
so in any case there are
this idea
of um i mean it gets in the actual sort
of uh
computer engineering
level of this gets fairly complicated
but the basic point is the unit of sort
of uh memory that you can reasonably
separately get
from the main memory of a computer is in
these 8-bit comps which are bytes even
though the individual pieces of memory
are just bits
by the way people have tried back in the
early days of computers people tried all
sorts of different configurations so
famously there was some actually russian
computers that used uh ternary instead
of using
bytes that could have just values sorry
bit in bits that were just zero and one
they could be well actually they usually
had zero one and minus one
and there are some algorithms that are
very can be done in a very cool way on
computers that have ternary um
ternary ways to represent their data but
it's a bit hard to understand and it
kind of didn't didn't make it um
and uh so so that that's um that's the
story of that
um
well i think um maybe i can say
uh
yeah i think this
this whole question of um i think
somebody had asked um
uh
about a sufficiently smart compiler
um
uh okay well first of all what does a
compiler do
so
if you have
so
intrinsically a microprocessor inside a
computer
knows how to do a certain set of
instructions those instructions are
things like
go to this address in memory and load
the data that's from there into some
register inside the cpu inside the
central processing unit another
instruction might say take the things in
registers one and two and add them
together and put the results in register
three
another thing might say
uh go to the next
uh
go to the next step in the program which
will be a uh picking another instruction
to do out of those machine code
instructions that are part of the the
ones in the the microprocessor so a
program
ends up being a sequence in the end a
sequence of machine code instructions
that say things like take the content of
register one add it to the content of
register six put the result in register
seven store register seven back in the
main memory of the computer
or another thing they could say is if
the value of register two is less than
zero
then skip the next machine code
instruction and go on to the one after
that or jump out of this whole list of
machine code instructions that you're
going to execute in sequence jump to
instruction number 137
um or
another
so those are that's the very lowest
level what the machine is doing at
that's what's built into the hardware of
the machine is those very low level
instructions
now
when you
write a program
uh in any programming language
um
you will be writing it at something much
higher level than that you will be
referring to the variable x
and you'll be saying you know if x is
greater than zero
uh
you know add two to x or something um
those are things you might might specify
that is in the language that you're
specifying things in that needs to be
compiled into machine language
ultimately for it to be executable on
machine there are there are
in broad categories there are two basic
ways that typical languages work to be
compiled so that you give the
specification of what you want to do in
that language and then there is a moment
where the effort has gone to to convert
that to machine code and then what
you're doing is just executing that
machine code that's done strategy number
one strategy number two is an
interpreter where at the moment where
that those uh instructions are going to
be executed then they
what what's happened is the language
is um like like an instruction like um
is x greater than zero
um instead of having turned that once
and for all into machine code
the the thing like if is implemented as
a bunch of machine code the x greater
than zero is implemented as a bunch of
machine code and that machine code is
executed at the time when when you're
actually running that program so in
compilation you convert everything to
the machine code once and for all and
interpreted when things are interpreted
you have the interpreter
that is written in machine code and that
is doing the things that the language
specifies to do and it's just doing it
as as the um as as one comes to that
place in the program in in the higher
level language
so
in fact in like well from language
there's a complicated combination of
interpreted and compiled kinds of things
that happen it's quite often that one
does uh
well one can do just in time compilation
where let's say one has something which
is going to be executed many times
okay i should explain when you do
compilation when you convert the program
to machine code that takes some effort
to do that we'll talk about what's
actually involved in doing it but it
takes some effort to do that
um
if you're going to but once you've done
it you have this very efficient thing in
machine code
um
and
so if you're going to execute something
10 000 times it might make sense
to
convert it to machine code once and for
all then just run the machine code 10
000 times if you're only going to
execute the thing once
well you probably don't want to pay the
cost of converting it to machine code
you just want to run the interpreted
code just run it once and you're done
so there are strategies like just in
time compilation we do a bunch of that
that um uh says if it looks like you can
do this a bunch of times like for
example in wolfram language if you're
going to make a plot
of a function it's going to evaluate
that function many many times so it
knows it's going to do that
so it compiles that function essentially
into machine code before it starts
having to evaluate it all those times
okay so
the um uh
what's involved in in making a compiler
um what's involved in converting from
the sort of high-level description of
things
down to machine code first i should
explain uh the notion of an assembler
when okay but back
okay when people started writing
programs for computers in the 1950s they
always throw to machine code they just
specified
in precise detail these are the things
that the hardware of the computer can do
i want the computer to do this then this
then this it's all written in machine
code
and so that meant for example that if
they said i want to store
the value of this
thing i want to store it in this
location in memory location 1726 in
memory they would put that number 1726
right there and that would be that that
program would have those literal numbers
in it
okay so then the next level up is to
make an assembler
where instead of having to have 1726
as a raw number you could for example
uh well actually actually i'm i'm i'm
getting ahead of myself here that the
first level
is just to um uh to not specify the in
in pure machine code you're specifying
the different instructions that you do
just as numbers themselves like the
instruction that says is this greater
than 0 or not that might be instruction
37
and you would just represent that
instruction as instruction 37
operating on memory location 1726
and your program would just be a series
of numbers actually a series of of uh
data in binary that's what the earliest
programs were like
um
in assemblers you end up with uh
not specifying the instructions um as
raw numbers um you can specify them as
some
as uh uh
you know by by giving them a name um you
know they'll have some standard name now
you know boy it's a long time since i
wrote assembly code
and i'm trying to remember how far this
goes i think um there are many other
kinds of sort of simplifications that
allow you that give you more structure
than just seeing the raw sequence of
numbers
but back
when
uh in
the 1970s
uh most serious programs were written in
assembly language and most programs that
exist today that started in the 1970s
are written in assembly language
um
by
there were other languages like fortran
um uh cobol
uh later by the late 1970s c language
and so on that it existed so those
languages
one of the big things those did
those do
is to let you give names to things so
instead of saying
uh you could say x
and x
is a variable that is going to be stored
in memory location 1726 but you're not
responsible for deciding where it's
going to be stored the computer is going
to do that automatically
and
and also you're able to uh
originally fortran which was invented in
the late 1950s the name fortran stood
for formula translation and so the idea
was you could write things like x plus y
times z
and that would be a formula that would
then be translated in the machine code
where that would the x would be at
location such and such the plus was this
machine instruction 72 or something etc
etc etc
so that was kind of the um but but at
the time
so in something like the c language um
you get to specify i want a variable x
now a very important point about when
you specify that variable x is you have
to say what type of variable is that you
know for example how many bits are you
going to use to store the value of x
for example x could be a 16-bit integer
then the
uh then
it it's going to be set up so that it
that x is going to be allocated
someplace in memory that will fit a
16-bit integer
um and so typically what happens is
you're specifying these different types
that are going to be used for different
variables
so a variable might be an int an integer
um it might be a a float a floating
point number it might be a double a
double precision floating point number
um
unfortunately in the because of the
evolution of computers there was a lot
of confusion about how long is an int
representing integer is it 16 bits is it
is it 32 bits is it 64 bits then there
was the idea of a long a short this is
in the c language at least
and these things that have gradually
migrated and got rather confused
but
in in basic terms when you specify a
variable in a low level language you are
specifying you have to specify the type
so that the language knows how that
variable will be will be laid out in
memory
so then
there are slightly more complicated
things like in c there are things called
structs
where you can say uh instead of just
saying i've got let's say you're trying
to represent uh
latitude longitude on the earth you
might make a struct which says i'm
always going to have two floating point
numbers in there but i'm going to refer
to them by a single named variable i
could call it x and the x has
this specification that has both a
latitude and a longitude so that's a
another sort of level of abstraction in
specifying things another critical idea
is the idea of an address
so for example uh you've got
this this uh variable or for example a
struct
and you've got this struct
and you want to
specify that struct for another part of
your program how do you refer to that
struct
well the typical way you would refer to
it is by the address of that struct by
saying where was that struct stored in
memory
and that's another kind of type of thing
is a pointer so-called pointer to memory
that's another type like integers and
floats as pointers
and um uh there's also an and that's
often used to when you have an array of
data you're going from from uh you
specify the the uh the zeroth element
the first elements et cetera et cetera
et cetera your your kind of those are
successive positions in memory and so
you're specifying those by giving a
pointer you you add something to the
pointer it's tricky because you have to
know what kind of data is being stored
in that array if it's 32-bit integers
you know you have to the the successive
pointers have to be four bytes larger to
go to the next integer in the sequence
if they were storing 64-bit integers
they'd have to be eight bytes larger to
get to the next integer so you have to
know that when you're doing all these
kinds of things
so what does the compiler do the
compiler basically is trying to convert
the code that you write in some
low-level language let's say
into
uh
it's trying to resolve all of the things
that you wrote down in your program and
resolve them ultimately into machine
code i should say there's another big
thing that you do in programs which is
to define functions you certainly have
some function f of x and it's going to
uh do this it's going to add 1 to x it's
going to return the result
how does that work
well
when you call a function
um
one of the things that has to happen is
you're running code and inside that code
there's a function that you call
and
the uh then
what the cpu has to start doing is
paying attention to what was the inside
of that function you've been running a
bunch of existing code then you call a
function cpu has to kind of say okay now
i've got to pay attention to what's
inside that function but there's all the
rest and then after that function
finishes it's got to return and go on
with the rest of the code and specify
okay so one of the things that's tricky
about that is when you're running a
piece of code maybe it has all these
variables x and y and z and so on and
you're storing those somewhere in memory
and then you're or you've you've got
those actually in in registers in the
cpu because they're being actively
worked with and then you call a function
f and it wants to use those registers
itself it wants to it wants to use them
for its own purposes
but you've still got that outer program
that is making use of those registers
and when the function returns you have
to restore the states of those registers
again so how does that work so the big
idea there is this thing called the
stack
um and the notion is it's like a stack
like a stack of plates
and the notion is when you uh are going
to call that inner function
all the things that were part of that
outer function get they are they are uh
well actually this is um
i've saying it's slightly the wrong way
around those things are stored on the
stack and when you um
uh
when you um uh when you call this
function you are you are putting more
variables you're allocating this the new
variables that you're going to use in
that function on the stack
when that function returns
that it's like you're taking that plate
back off the stack and the plates that
were underneath it kind of come up to
the top again
and so that mechanism of the stack
is is the way that you call
you you call uh functions within
functions within functions you're
pushing you're going further down on the
stack
a typical way that a computer's memory
is laid out
is it has
a memory that is allocated on the stack
for use temporarily within functions and
then it has another kind of memory
called heap memory which is memory that
is sort of more permanently used in your
program and isn't doesn't just sort of
go away when the function that makes use
of of that memory exits so to explain
this a little bit more clearly uh
typical thing is that in a function you
will say there are some local variables
within this function
that are things that the function is
operating on those are allocated memory
on the stack when that function exits
that memory is automatically given back
to the operating system in a typical
setup you've got this memory address
space where every piece of memory is
specified by a particular numerical
address and the typical model is that
the heap is memory addresses coming up
from zero and the stack is memory
address is coming up from coming down
from the maximum value
often many operating systems will
allocate a fixed amount of stack to a
particular program so if you have too
deeply nested a sequence of functions it
will just it will blow up its memory not
because it really ran out of memory but
because the memory that was allocated
for this kind of um uh you know
stalactite that was coming down from the
top of memory space um was was not
enough not enough was allocated to it
okay so that's a little bit of sort of
the low levels of what's happening when
you are taking something like a program
written in a low level language like c
and turning it into machine code
but
uh all of that stuff happens
automatically in a compiler you just
write your seek program and it is
converted to specify how things should
work in machine code
and so how does that work now i should
say just to sort of zoom ahead when we
get to something like well from language
all of this detail about type types and
memory allocation all these kinds of
things you never have to do that this
has all been automated away this is the
this is you know something like watson
language is just a much higher level uh
way of interacting with a computer and
all of those low-level details are
things you don't have to worry about
but let me explain how a compiler for a
low-level language works
what you're going to try to do
is to take um
uh
well let's see the the
in the lowest level languages you
specify the type of everything
so
you what the language
really has to do what the compiler has
to do
is to say okay this function is
allocating two integers and one real
number
on on the stack okay what does that
actually mean in machine code it means i
have to allocate this number of bytes of
memory do that
it says um in the length in the language
it says you know if x is greater than
seven
go to this place in the code or switch
on these values to decide which piece of
code to run
all of that has to get converted into
raw machine code in the end and that's
and what the compiler typically does
is
it
uh
will the first thing it does is there's
the raw code that you've written bunch
of characters you typed in it makes a
thing called an abstract syntax tree
which is kind of an internal data
representation
of the the thing that you typed it turns
if you say
x plus y times z
it turns that into kind of a tree
structure that says there's a plus at
the top and it's got an x on one side
and it's then on the other side it's got
something which is a sub piece of the
tree of times of y and z
that's what uh for example if you look
at full form in wolfram language you see
the actual tree structure which wolven
language directly uses as a way of
representing symbolic expressions but in
in a in a typical kind of uh uh compiler
what the first stage is to take the raw
text that you've written and turn it
into this kind of tree structured uh
thing that represents kind of where all
these different operations all these
different pieces of the program are
represented in a sort of hierarchical
way
okay so then
there's all sorts of analysis that has
to be done to figure out you know how
much memory do you allocate for this how
do you how do you arrange that to that
eventually you're going to generate code
you are going to actually produce the
machine code from these different uh
pieces of
different specifications of operations
there's often an intermediate language
that you convert into before you convert
to the raw machine code so for example
these days there's a thing called llvm
low-level virtual machine
which is a kind of a somewhat
standardized intermediate language that
is sort of the next level up before
you're converting directly into the
machine code and by the way machine code
will be different for each particular
kind of machine
and um uh
so that's you can have this intermediate
language which is the same for different
machines or at least somewhat the same
not quite the same even at that level
that then gets converted into pure
machine code okay the tricky part of
compilation is optimization
and
what optimization is about is
okay there are many different machine
codes sequences and machine code
instructions which could all achieve the
same result which one should you use
and so i'll give you an example of one
tricky thing
so-called register allocation
so let's say that your cpu has
well the real number will be much larger
than this but let's say your cpu has
four really fast pieces of memory really
fast registers
and you've got a program
that has 20 variables in it
20 things that are going to be stored
that could be stored in registers okay
as you go through actually executing the
program
of those 20 things that could be stored
and registered
at any given moment
uh you can only have four of those
stored in actual in these actual fast
registers which ones should you store so
that's an example of a a kind of
operation that is done by compilers is
to figure out based on the structure of
your code it may know oh these are the
four that are being used in this section
of the code we don't have to worry about
these other ones we can bring those in
later actually the way that register
allocation is usually done is a clever
algorithm invented actually by a friend
of mine long ago
um which is that if you imagine a graph
that sort of is a connections between
this piece of code depends on this other
piece of code
you're saying how the sort of flow of
data goes from one piece of code to
another and you imagine coloring the
nodes on the graph
and or or numbering the nodes on the
graph but let's say coloring and you
have red green blue
purple or something
and then the it will the question of
whether you can allocate
uh two
things to the same register ends up
boiling down to the question of whether
you can how you color the graph so that
you never have two red nodes next to
each other
um it's a little bit more complicated
than that but that's that's sort of the
idea so you're you're figuring out how
to arrange where you put the regis where
you put the specifications the registers
on this graph so that you will never
have this collision and that's how you
allocate register so that would be an
example of a compiler operation but
there are many others in fact it's not
uncommon to do i guess called people
compilation
where you'll actually just take
uh pieces of the machine code and
essentially randomly rearrange them and
uh to try and find the one that works
fastest and if it's a small enough
number of instructions there's a decent
chance that you know you try a thousand
possibilities one of them will be right
no human may necessarily have ever
figured out that that was a better way
to write that piece of code
but the computer could figure it out
just by
sort of proving a theorem that that
piece of code is equivalent to the thing
that you originally had
so over the years optimization in
compilers for a while it was a very slow
process when you would compile something
you'd say i want a low optimization
level i i don't need this code to be
super fast i just don't want the
compilation to take 15 minutes
and then gradually over time compilation
uh optimization has gotten faster and um
uh at this point even up to the highest
levels of optimization you can typically
do it very fast
um but that's kind of the the sort of
the main kind of neat thing in compilers
is that you can do this optimization
what does that mean that means that
there was long ago in the 1970s early
1980s um if a human were to write
assembly code
they could do much better job than any
compiler could do
but
by now
most of the time an optimizing compiler
will vastly outperform a human in terms
of making a good assembly code good
machine code
for something
so i mean just to give a sense of how it
gets a little bit more complicated than
this if this wasn't complicated enough
uh for example in wolfram language where
we have a much higher level
representation of what's going on
we also have compilation and actually
for example right now we we're building
a a much more sophisticated compiler for
orphan language one of the things that's
tricky there
is type inference
so you have i said well x is an integer
it fits it like x is a 32-bit integer it
fits in you can allocate just 32 bits of
memory to store this integer okay well
in wolverine language there are no types
just x is whatever x to be x could be an
integer it could be an integer with 100
digits
it could be a um
it could be a just a string it could be
a could be some whole structure it could
be anything
and
what we have to do in order to make
efficient to do efficient compilation is
we have to take a program and we have to
analyze that program and say okay in
this program or in the section of this
program x will always be an integer less
than uh
which will fit in 32 bits
or it will be either an integer that
fits in 32 bits or it will be a real
number of this characteristic or
whatever else and so what ends up
happening is you're building up this
kind of type calculus
of given this piece of code let me give
an example
let's say that
you have x
is a list of integers
okay now the piece of code says
select the first element of x
well if x was a list of integers the
first element of x is necessarily going
to be just a single integer so you can
deduce the type of that part first part
of x from the type of x
now it gets more complicated let's say
you have something where you have a a
function um
that uh
uh takes in
a um
some symbolic structure that looks like
this gives one that looks like this
um
that that becomes a much more
complicated piece of kind of
mathematical type analysis sort of proof
you're making these proofs of how types
should be inferred and so on
so i think what was asked here was
somebody else what i meant by a
sufficiently smart compiler um
i'm not sure exactly what context that
was but but um this whole question about
sort of how memory is how things are
laid out in memory
how
um oh yeah i was i was talking about um
uh things like
um
you know in morphing language for
example when we have to
in the compiler when we have to actually
specify how things are laid out in
memory the the compiler has to figure
out things about how to clump things
together so that the memory will be
pulled in in the right kind of gulps and
so on um i mean it's it's a it's a
fairly complicated and deep piece of
essentially computer science to figure
out how all this stuff should work i
mean it used to be the case back in the
day that the field of computer science
one of the the definite things that was
always taught back in the 1970s when
computer science was a much more
embryonic field was compiler design
there was a sad moment i think when the
total number of people in the world who
were writing compilers was like in the
tens of people yet it was a thing that
was taught in a hundred percent of
computer science courses um and so it
was kind of a bit of an imbalance and
that's still true very few people write
compilers um it's an interesting type of
largest program to talk about
um and uh so it's sort of educational
value for that reason but it's
definitely not in terms of practitioners
uh you know writing compilers is a
specialized task
uh
okay
let's see
um
i think i'm almost running out of time
but but um
um
oh i was going to say one more thing
about compilation
um
the
one of the issues is what's the target
for the compiler so cpus
are the usual target for compilers gpus
graphics processing units
which
have their data organized differently
and have different kinds of instructions
they are a whole new challenge for
compilers
which has not yet been
been really
completely met
that is how do you take a program that
was written in some language we already
have and how do you convert it to
something that can run efficiently on a
gpu that's that's an example of sort of
a frontier of that kind of thing
um
let's see richard is commenting about
lifting of programs to other forms of
representation
in which
one could make
do more efficient optimization yeah i
mean this whole question about what the
right representation of a program is to
best be able to manipulate the program i
mean
for example let me give you an example
again
it's a concept called tail recursion
so let's say you have a function
now you have a function f and let's say
it even calls itself
the function f
says i want to take um
well
this is kind of
coding in the air so to speak let me
basically the function f let's say takes
as an argument some number it
does something to that number and then
it calls itself with that number minus
one and it keeps doing that until the
number reaches zero let's say so then
you have a big nested collection of f f
calling f calling f calling that's
calling f
um that makes a deep recursion
and
f calling f
is typically something that takes it
takes the computer a certain amount of
time to prepare the stack to do the
function call et etc etc but if what's
happening inside that f is just the f is
sort of calling itself again on its way
out
you don't really need to do that
recursive call you can turn that whole
thing into a pure iteration where the
thing just loops over do this then this
then this then this without it having to
go sort of inside recursively called
functions and so that's the type of
transformation of tail recursion uh
tail call optimization i think it's
recorded more commonly these days
um where you kind of unroll that
recursion into something into something
flatter
but so one of the things that is rather
interesting to look at is
if you kind of try and make this graph
representing sort of the flow of of
control in a program and the flow of
data in a program uh you let make this
split off it's a big tangled mess
for some particular complicated program
you've written is there a way
of sort of refactoring that graph so
that it is more efficiently run on a
computer and actually some of the things
we've been doing recently with kind of
um
uh representing uh evaluation graphs in
wolfram language may give us a way to to
understand that one of the issues okay
another issue here if you've got a
computer that has not just one cpu but
it has multiple cpus or it has multiple
cores on that cpu multi a core is a part
of the cpu which can independently
execute instructions so a modern
uh a modern cpu chip might have eight
cores 16 cores i don't know more cores
on it
and each one of those cores can be
running different instructions
and so you can in in terms of operating
systems particularly you can talk about
different threads
where and sometimes within a single
program you can talk about different
threads where each
core on your on your microprocessor chip
is running a different thread it's
running a different piece of the program
okay so if you've got a program
most programs are executed you do this
then you do this thing this thing do
this
but the question is can you in fact
execute many things in parallel so for
example let's say you have a big list of
numbers and you're going to add one to
every number in that list
well you could do that by adding one to
the first number of the list then adding
one to the second number in the list
then adding one to the third number in
the list and so on or if you happen to
have multiple cores or multiple cpus you
could just say okay we've got eight cpus
let's distribute those numbers in that
that list of numbers across those
different cpus let's have one cpu add
one to the first number another cpu add
one to the second number and so on and
then collect the data back together
again
so that kind of parallelism in
involvement language for example we have
functions that basically will try and
execute things in parallel like that
across multiple cpus
but one of the questions for for a
sophisticated compiler is to see whether
you can do that automatically whether
you can figure out yes you can actually
use multiple threads now it's a tricky
thing for the compiler because the
process of starting a new thread and
getting that all set up that can be a
fairly expensive process so if it
doesn't if there's not a bunch to do
within those threads separately there's
no point in doing that so it has to kind
of optimize is it worth just barreling
through and doing this doing this sort
of sequential execution or is it worth
having the extra sort of startup cost of
setting up multiple threads and so on um
and that's
that's another kind of frontier of
compilation but it's something where
these evaluation graphs that we're
looking at um i think we may have a
framework for understanding kind of when
you can do things in parallel and when
you have to do them sequentially um it's
almost you can imagine a graph where you
you're saying these are these are sort
of threads of execution and you can just
look at the picture and see these ones
can be done in parallel oh these ones
one depends on another they have to be
done in sequence
and that's that's kind of the the
challenge of doing those kinds of things
and it's a it's a tricky business
because
the
in
in wolfram language for example uh it's
a rather clean you can use it as a
rather clean functional programming
language which means that everything
you're operating on is just a function
being applied to the results of another
function and so on with that set up you
can much more untangle this whole
question about what depends on what
than if you have something in typical
and lower level languages you will have
something where you are sort of storing
things in named variables and then you
have kind of the the interdependence of
things is oh this variable that got set
over here is used in this other part of
the code here and there's kind of a much
more
at a distance kind of mechanism that's
going on about how data is flowing
through the
through the code
well okay i think um
we spent our whole time here talking
about some uh
details of of computers hopefully that
was of interest to to people here um
these these sort of engineering rabbit
holes
um
uh there is there is considerably more
in this rabbit hole but i think i
touched on
if i didn't forget something i think i
touched on the main
kind of uh
first level chamber of the rabbit hole
so to speak um uh most of the pieces of
that um
and uh that was kind of a a a rough
summary of of um of some aspects of how
how computers work i didn't talk about i
just talked about individual programs i
didn't talk about things like operating
systems and so on uh people are
interested they have to talk about that
so other time um
but uh
that's some that's that story
right i am supposed to go back to my
day job which um
involves uh uh
see i've built this kind of tower of
tools
that you know back in the 1970s i
programmed an assembly language but ever
since the beginning of the 80s i've kind
of built my own tools that are uh very
high above that level of programming and
allow one to kind of the sort of goal of
our kind of orphan language
computational language
is to uh have a language where one can
uh what can
the language represents the way one
thinks about things
computationally
rather than kind of
representing the sort of low-level what
are the operations that a computer can
intrinsically do
and so for me sort of operating at that
level of how do i think about things is
vastly more efficient than having to
operate at the level of well let me
worry about how this particular piece of
memory in the computer should get used
and oh i didn't even talk about memory
allocation and you know i'm gonna store
this now in the memory of the computer
oh i'm not using that anymore i've got
to free that piece of memory oh i forgot
to free that piece of memory all sorts
of things went wrong or i freed that
piece of memory while i was still using
it oops
all those kinds of things that is many
many many layers down
from the way that i for example uh you
know use computational language or the
way that both language is set up um
it's the whole point is to kind of
automate all of that stuff away so us
humans don't have to think about those
kinds of things but it's the job of of
those of us who build the language to
make it not just as efficient to do it
with those things abstracted away but
even more efficient than it would be if
you were to go down in the trenches
and start writing those things by hand
see the reason it can be more efficient
is that the computer is smarter of doing
optimization than any human is going to
be
and the real issue is can the computer
know enough about what you really want
to do
have the whole structure in its mind so
to speak so that it knows what how to do
that optimization that's a much better
setup than you going in the trenches and
trying to do the optimization yourself
but it's then the the burden is put on
the folks who are writing the system
that is sort of automatically doing that
optimization and that's kind of us in
the case of language and that's the kind
of thing we've been doing for the last
35 years is building that kind of tower
of capabilities sort of that take you
far above the level of sort of the
intrinsic features of a computer most
programming languages traditional
programming languages really do not take
you far above the intrinsic operations
of a computer they deal with things like
uh allocation of memory they deal with
naming pieces of memory and things like
that but they don't
deal with um all of the other kinds of
things of representing things in the
world uh you know they they don't have
an intrinsic way of representing i don't
know an image or a graph or something
like that
um
so uh
anyway um all right i should stop here
but thank you all for
for for joining me and um i see
questions about completely different
kinds of things about
ocean tides and stem cells and so on and
i look forward to talking about those
next time
so thanks very much and